[Music]
alright be brought to our attention
yesterday that I fail to follow through
my desk yesterday says hey I've got a
good idea for a lobby segment Nintendo
is releasing these 10-minute episodes
behind the scenes making documentaries
of breadth of the wild so I say cool
let's all watch that so we can talk
about it Jake and Callie watched it I
watched the whole I gave these people
homework and they didn't do it
I watched all 30 minutes was third grade
I would put you in detention today
what's art school that's not third grade
you get a pink slip they just they put
you in that closet where you can't eat
for a day good no mm-hmm okay but yeah
so we want to talk about that some cool
stories came out of it I wrote on notes
but it's worth watching I don't think
there's anything revelatory but there
are some cool things behind like the art
inspiration that's one thing I want to
talk about but just like how where the
influence came from because you know
like as great as that game is in fact
like fantastic we've talked about it P
you gave it a ten out of ten you can go
read the review on game spotted yeah and
we did episode of reboot which I'm gonna
plug right now Jake and I have been
working on this new show if you missed
like Daniel Dwyers the point that's
clear inspiration for us more of opinion
editorial show a series and then
biweekly show our most recent episode
was on breath the wild and why I
personally think it's like the best open
real game ever made in that sense a new
benchmark for other games and I think it
does things that The Witcher didn't I
think those things that meld your solid
5 did and not that they are all the same
game in any way but I think open world
games moving forward can learn a lot
from breath awhile we did an episode
about that and it was pretty cool for
the documentary because they talked
about how you know like you start with
Skyward Sword right it's just open air
concept although it was kind of masking
the fact that the world below was very
very even for a Zelda game segmented
right so I did watch a little bit of the
first episode and they talked about the
open air concept like almost at the
start it's been something they've been
trying to capture since wind waker yeah
because it opens like the seafaring
rebel yeah but it seems like up until
now it's been hardware limitations and
the team size now now that the switch is
like a crazy
powerful console but it seems like just
enough for them to capture their vision
and then they had just the biggest team
behind a Nintendo game ever mm-hmm so I
think those things kind of came together
for them here yeah and they said you
know they wanted to recapture the
feeling of exploration which they've
been saying since the beginning but when
we first heard because when they
announced this correct me if I'm wrong
link between worlds was not even out
when they first announced the concept
for breath of the wild right because
better they said when they announced it
that you will not have to do dungeons in
a certain order it'll be open world so
how the [ __ ] is that gonna work and as
always sorry you even have to do the
deities right and we're house that can
work and then link between worlds came
out we're like oh this is cool like they
take a Link to the Past formula and show
us how it can work with this top-down
view but still we've never seen like a
truly open world Zelda game before comes
out not only is it just open-world but
it's also these this like physics engine
that you can I was reading through that
neogaf forum last night the craziest
things you do in breadth of the while
that you a lot of people don't know I
think I'm like I'm 45 50 hours into the
game at this point and I was still
reading things I had no idea what you
could do yeah of course there's the
classic things like this they said they
wanted to maintain a lot of this all
that tenets say that's the footage they
chose to show was the chickens and
Kakariko chasing you after we like knife
a couple of them knife one a couple
times but yeah they said they took when
they first showed they did the GDC talk
a couple weeks ago and they are saying
that to show the concept they took like
this 8-bit original Legend of Zelda look
to show how the physics engine could
work with a the thing they showed was
obviously you get the raft in the first
game you can cross the river but they
show it how like a log floating down
rather than this item you get could help
you cross the river and then you play
breath of the wild and it's you know
you're chopping down trees and you can
roll the trunks or you can use the
trunks to cross these ravines they said
that physics engine was a huge focus and
they said and I agree that in execution
it ties you to the world a little more
right there's this there are these
overlapping systems and then like I was
saying people come in every day I feel
like still after how many weeks after
it's released and we're all at least
like 40 hours and we're finding these
new things it was very intentional on
their part that you could find new ways
to approach the situation well they tie
into I think the most basic actions that
you do in the game which is simply just
you know tied to exploration in general
like you don't have to wait to get to
likes a meal you're Solid five you don't
have to wait to like confront enemies
for your doing the creative stuff right
you can be creative at any time in
breadth of the wild yeah in the
documentary they specifically
specifically call out that they wanted
everything in the world to interact and
that's how they they got that feel like
the consistent discovery you get I mean
like you said we come in every day and
someone found something new or like like
a mob 'ln through but goblin at me or
whatever it is all of that is because
they put a lot of their effort
technically and as far as overall
direction goes into making things
interact together mm-hmm that was one of
the most interesting parts of the
documentary for me when they talk about
the open world I think it was known
before I came out didn't it what I think
we had a new story GameSpot about how
the geography of this high role is based
on Kyoto so I think yeah we maybe we
published something about that or was it
when you you talked to who did you talk
to recently uh stood the three directors
that have been represented here by AH
she yeah she but there's two other guys
and I apologize for not knowing their
names I actually wasn't really aware of
them until the interview but I mean like
based on Kyoto is kind of loosely I mean
the good thing about Kyoto is that it's
just it's still sort of steeped in
tradition compared to a place like Tokyo
and so you do see like even when you're
in the city of Kyoto it's not hard to
get to an environment that feels like
nature still has some hold mm-hmm on
space so I think that's kind of what
they were they were mentioning and one
of the more interesting anecdotes sort
of talking them about like okay well you
know this made me think about even just
going outside my front door differently
like I was looking at you can just like
twigs on the ground and I don't know why
like what is it about this game and one
of the things we wanted to do was
recreate that feeling of being like a
child at school right like every day you
walk the same route and you get to
understand like not just landmarks but
like what those landmarks contain and so
you you you have this is really deep
familiarity with your environment and
what you can get out of it so that's not
really the Kyoto aspect of it but it's
it's it's sort of just telling like how
deeply they thought about making even
something that looks like empty space
interesting by packing in with with very
subtle activities well one of the
Tavella
first in the documentaries talking about
how because he's from Kyoto and because
Nintendo is based in Kyoto they he
thought about it as like okay I'm so
familiar with this city that I know how
tired I would be if I walked across the
entire city and that's sort of where
that Kyoto inspiration comes from as far
as like the the depth of the world and
how it feels to walk across if you were
going to walk across the entire map
which sounds free and impossible and so
that was a big thing and then the other
thing I really liked I'm just going off
of like the Kyoto being steeped in
traditionalism was they were talking
about the art style for the sheikah
culture like the ancient cultures based
off the Jomon period which is a period
historical period in Japan that not a
lot of people outside Japan know about
which is crazy because it's like twelve
thousand years long or something the
actual period that they when you say Joe
Moana it's like actually four different
periods within it yeah something yes is
that correct I can't remember now but
the the point was we're taking
inspiration from something real because
it's such a mysterious time periods in
our history that not a lot of people
know about so it's not going to kind of
you vote you know connotations of any
culture that people really recognize
readily I mean that's another horizon
comparisons there's lots of things in
horizon that gave up cultures that we
know and see today versus this is
something that a lot of people didn't
really know about before and I didn't
know about before watching the
documentary and so that's where all the
smooth surfaces and kind of the when you
open a shrine and the the doors kind of
open in that we I don't even looks like
Jenga almost all of that comes from the
gentleman period yeah I was interesting
they're saying also like when you're
saying who do who do they work with to
like work on the elevation of the
monoliths off and that's huge between
the glider the paraglider and the fact
you can climb almost anything there are
few surfaces you can't climb but very
few like that makes the game feel very
different like the actual again I say
this all the time but today actually
it's not open-world for the sake of it
it's like they actually recaptured the
joy of an open-world game in that just
exploring it's fun I don't feel
I know there's two more divine beasts I
have to get I know there's a desert I
haven't even gone to yeah I know it's
like this whole mountainous area with
you know these the Rideau the bird
people up there and I don't even care
because I know I'm gonna get there but
I'm enjoying this traveling it makes the
art of moving from one place to another
fun again where so many games design
their open worlds to funnel you into
something in particular like yeah there
are those aspects of the map here where
it's like okay I see a path or I see a
canyon but you just can go anywhere and
find something interesting yeah you know
it's just a crock seed there's that
moment of like okay wait what else is
out there if I just took a left here and
found something random I could take a
left anywhere yeah I keep getting so
distracted like I'm working on guide
stuff and I I have a mission in mind
that it has been artificially created
for me but I still like I take an extra
hour to go do something because I just
can't stop myself and like I think I
said several episodes ago it reminds me
of that feeling of playing ocarina for
the first time and seeing death mountain
in the distance and thinking like I can
actually go there like and what I can
walk all the way there and it's that
times a thousand yeah sorry I was just
gonna say one thing I think that I think
Peter touched on a little bit but the
landmarks are like so important in this
game and they're so cool because when I
went to talk to some people at CD
Projekt RED about The Witcher 3 a while
ago they were saying how when you make a
big world landmarks are very important
like that's how you get around without
like just looking at your map the entire
time and this like I rarely open my map
because there's all these landmarks
everywhere like you walk out and you're
like okay so death mountains over there
like I can see the Rudo village like
they've got that spire over there
there's some towers around here and just
that kind of helps add to that sort of
immersion that sort of level of
exploration they also does a really good
job of you know it's not all of a sudden
a desert from a grassland you see this
transition area where it's like oh it's
kind of getting these crags and ravines
and the vegetation is fading away
maybe there's a desert this way or you
see your thermometer slowly dropping
you're like well I'm heading north but
I'm also like increasing my elevation if
you're not a death mountain it's just
getting colder it does a really good job
of tying all these areas together like I
know this river is gonna eventually lead
to you know the lake so I might as well
follow it rather than looking at my map
and you can also you know like looking
through your view finders big you could
set waypoints through your sheikah slate
the
telescope and that's huge and I like
that they didn't one thing I think
horizon did well too and which mass
effect does not from the two hours of
play and we'll get into it was kinda
reminds me of Arkham Asylum in that I
was always in detective mode and then in
Mass Effect I'm always I hate pulling
out that scanner yeah
Zelda does a really good job of not
forcing you into the map even though you
kind of feel like you're you know you're
revealing the map but it's not it's not
like Far Cry right you could go to this
radio tower and then all of a sudden
these side quests all pop up it's it's
just showing you the land you select
ographers you still have to find the
activities data and then you are
deciphering like what you see on the map
and I really liked when they talked
about in the behind the scenes thing
about their concept of link in this I
really like the idea that for the first
time you're not this hero that was just
chosen like you're not one of the
ancestors of this hero you are this hero
who you yourself failed in this quest
and the same exact quest a hundred years
ago and now you're back like for a
chance at redemption essentially but I
also really like that they said you can
make link not really that heroic in this
game you can fight bulk oblems in these
underhanded ways by like blowing up
these barrels when you're sneaking
around or steal their weapons first
you're not this noble charge into every
battle with your sword and shield drawn
you can be this like you little dick you
can also say sorry Hyrule and Zelda I
don't care about you yeah and spend over
a hundred hours in this game anyway you
can close the book on this game without
finishing it and still feel hundred
percent satisfied yeah Dan Anderssen and
Twitter was asking what our opinions on
the divine beasts and dungeons are in
breadth of the wild and we can get to
that really quick but I also don't
really think of rather every other Zelda
game I kind of judged by its dungeons I
think Twilight Princess for as much Jake
you and I were replaying it recently and
I don't love that game as much as I used
to and I don't think I'm gonna like a
lot of Zelda games as much as I used to
of course cuz breath awhile came along
but there's still great for their own
reasons and for that Zelda formula you
know eight dungeons you collect all
these kind of arbitrary items that allow
you to go fight Ganon at the end or you
know agony whoever does did I pronounce
that correct agony
yeah yeah but Twilight Princess itself I
was like oh those actually has great
dungeons for as slow as the overworld
can be but now give these for you know
major dungeons these divine beasts but
there
actually that long the first one right
like I mean the I say the first but you
could have in any order a lot of people
did a specific one first
yeah the Kakariko potato village trout
kind of leaves you tool in a row where
the zora are but I don't know I thought
they're well-designed you know you can
actually I don't want to spoil too much
but you can actually mess with the
dungeon in cool ways yeah and that is
the the crux of all of these dungeons I
like the fact that they weren't too long
yeah and they're not filled with like oh
you got to find a key to open a door to
find a map to get another key and it's
just like none of that stuff which I
actually grew kind of tired of as Elbaz
went on so here it was more just about
really looking at the dungeon and
considering it for what how it presented
itself to you it is and then
manipulating it to accomplish these
little tasks and I'm a lot less
intimidated to start a dungeon like if
I'm if it's like 11:00 p.m. and I'm like
I should probably go to bed or I'll do
one last shrine partially because that
gives you a fast travel point when you
complete a shrines so that encourages
exploration too
but also they're so self-contained and I
always found that it if I just took a
breath and looked at it it wouldn't take
me too long to figure it out but I would
always be pretty much always be
satisfied with solving whatever it was
um
and so I like that they're
self-contained and it kind of fits I
play a played exclusively in handheld
mode it also fits that style for me
really well yeah I guess
I love the dungeon design or dungeon
quote-unquote yeah Bob Jones the twitch
I was saying he just ignored the first
village Kakariko which is kind of your
first real objective of the few you have
after that they kind of just let you
loose I mean they let you blue stray
from the beginning if you want to once
you get off the plateau which kind of
serves the tutorial but a very well made
tutorial in that you can I say tutorial
loosely because I'm not holding your
hand like a lot of games do now like a
lot of Nintendo games for the past few
years having specifically Zelda games
have especially like Skyward Sword the
one thing people just like about that as
fee your companion kind of like solves
puzzles for you in some ways and this is
the well plus the intro to that game was
like two hours of yeah Shing you what a
video game is yeah I mean in retrospect
Ocarina felt fast cuz you if you know
where to get the Kokiri sword you can go
get that really quick through that small
labyrinth through that crawl space and
then you can go buy the Deku shield once
get 40 rupees but that was quick and
then you go right to the Deku Tree now
link you're in these boxer briefs you're
staring out over this world go just do
whatever you want I mean obviously there
are a couple things to kind of guide you
but it's not it respects your
intelligence subscribe yeah yeah but
yeah so that's someone who's asking
forgive me miss their name but in twitch
chat if you think like far cry games
would be better without that you know
map littered with side quests and
notifications can't because you turn
those off I think but again I think
open-world games going forward can look
at Zelda you know granted it was a huge
team that made it but not everyone might
not have the tone in Tendo was pretty
good with you know well I think a huge
reason they wanted to hold off because
they said in the documentary they really
wanted to get early 2016 release once
like the time came up but then they're
like I will just hold off I'm sure the
switch really state once they knew that
internally they kind of dictated maybe
the cell doesn't launched yes that was
yeah so good move because people are
buying switches left and right beat what
I think I hit one one-and-a-half million
sold yesterday yeah which is huge and
good because I don't know what the Wii U
is that at this point how many weeks
after release - I think it's thirty
three million over its lifetime which is
and now or two weeks after the switch
release and it's already at one and a
half yeah I might be wrong with 33 but I
think that's what I saw
possible to get one - yeah I mean yeah
knows but yeah but anyway I encourage
you there like I said there's nothing
revelatory in that behind the scenes
docked a Nintendo publish but it's worth
watching if you really like that game I
just want to see more about it also you
should watch our reboot episode called
uh what we call it lesson is all the
breath of the wild the open-world game
we need that yeah that sounds right yeah
it's been I've taken a couple days off
because I've been playing Mass Effect
Andromeda which we have we can only talk
about the early hours right now we'll
get into that in a second if you're here
for that but yeah go watch that
behind-the-scenes documentary Nintendo
publish it we have a metric we have a
lot of it's all the content up on
GameSpot so you can go watch that Jake's
done a lot of stuff Pete's and a lot of
stuff Pete gave the game a ten out of
ten one of how many like I think
twelve or thirteen in our 21 year plus
history
yeah the Metacritic not to bring this up
but it was at what 98 right and now it's
at 97 because of the whole Jim sterling
debacle people are pissed off that we
didn't like it yeah it's still it's
still I think it's an amazing game go
play it yourself but yeah that behind
the scenes documentary shed some light
on it and like I said we have a lot of
stuff up yeah and actually to that point
sort of some of the things documentary
is talking about working on a future
still kind of just trying to get out
there about their process of you know
identifying nature in this game and in
creating and what they were thinking so
if you like the documentary stuff keep
an eye out for that as well is that from
the GDC chat with yes GDC chat I'll be
pulling a little bit from the
documentaries they just released and
then sort of my own interpretations of
what they've done cool so yeah like I
said that stuff is all up on GameSpot
and will be soon and we're still working
on a lot of stuff so go check that out
[Music]